is there cool small projects like uh
archive sanity and and so on that you're
thinking about the the the the world the
ml world can anticipate
there's some always like some fun side
projects yeah um archive sanity is one
uh yeah basically like there's way too
many archive papers how can I organize
it uh and uh recommend papers and so on
uh I transcribed all of your yeah
podcasts what did you learn from that
experience uh from transcribing the
process of like you like consuming
audiobooks and and podcasts and so on
and here's a process that achieves
um closer to human level performance and
annotation yeah well I definitely was
like surprised that uh transcription
with opening eyes whisper was working so
well compared to what I'm familiar with
from Siri and like a few other systems I
guess it works so well and
uh that's what gave me some energy to
like try it out and I thought it could
be fun to random podcasts it's kind of
not obviously why
whisper is so much better compared to
anything else because I feel like there
should be a lot of incentive for a lot
of companies to produce transcription
systems and that they've done so over a
long time whisper is not a super exotic
model it's a Transformer it takes smell
spectrograms and you know just outfits
tokens of text it's not crazy uh the
model and everything has been around for
a long time
I'm not actually 100 sure why yeah it's
not obvious to me either it makes me
feel like I'm missing something I'm
missing something yeah because there's a
huge even at Google and so on YouTube uh
transcription yeah
um yeah it's unclear but some of it is
also integrating into a bigger system
yeah that so the user interface how it's
deployed and all that kind of stuff
maybe running it as an independent thing
is eat much easier like an order of
magnitude easier than deploying to a
large integrated system like YouTube
transcription or
um anything like meetings like Zoom has
trans uh transcription that's kind of
crappy but creating uh interface where
it detects the different individual
speakers it's able to
um
display it in compelling ways Run in
real time all that kind of stuff maybe
that's difficult but that's the only
explanation I have because like um
I'm currently paying uh quite a bit for
human uh transcription human caption
right annotation and like it seems like
uh there's a huge incentive to automate
that yeah it's very confusing and I
think I mean I don't know if you looked
at some of the whisper transcripts but
they're quite good they're good and
especially in tricky cases yeah I've
seen
uh Whispers performance on like super
tricky cases and it does incredibly well
so I don't know a podcast is pretty
simple it's like high quality audio and
you're speaking usually pretty clearly
and so I don't know it uh I don't know
what open ai's plans are yeah either but
yeah there's always like fun fun
projects basically and stable diffusion
also is opening up a huge amount of
experimentation I would say in the
visual realm and generate generating
images and videos and movies like videos
now and so that's going to be pretty
crazy uh that's going to that's going to
almost certainly work and it's going to
be really interesting when the cost of
content creation is going to fall to
zero you used to need a painter for a
few months to paint a thing and now it's
going to be speak to your phone to get
your video so if Hollywood will start
using that to generate scene
um which completely opens up yeah so you
can make a like a movie like Avatar
eventually for under a million dollars
much less maybe just by talking to your
phone I mean I know it sounds kind of
crazy